I've been on this purified water steamed
vegetable diet okay and I was doing it
for sixty days right and then I was
allowed to introduce potatoes
okay little carbs and then I was allowed
to introduce meat for one meal a day but
I haven't had steak in 70 days Wow
I I you know I try to live my daily
regimen a little bit like what you're
saying I try to go meet one meal a day
and not always red meat I try to limit
the red meat a little bit but I have a
little theme there I go beans not beef
right you know I can't even have that I
can't have tofu hummus right not now
what is that what does that do to you I
went to a homeopathic doc yep right and
he said I gotta make you more alkaline
yeah so I drink at least a 100 ounces of
warm water a day right and so that's
what my new regimen has been and we have
meet Friday here where I have the best
meals on the Traeger grill and then I
watch these guys eat meat oh that's like
torture yes it is that's torture I might
have just a little taste today you
feeling good though it makes you feel
good this regimen I'm no not yet okay
I'm ready to kill some but I think it's
just frustrating because you're going
okay myself what am I supposed to feel
well maybe that's instead of killing
somebody why don't you just maybe eat
some red meat let's just do that
okay all right so final hour here we'll
take some of your phone calls here
football questions for Chris kind enough
to stay with us Clay Matthews the Rams
linebacker will join us in about 15-20
minutes awesome Broncos beat the Falcons
in the Hall of Fame game we talked about
pass interference review making its
debut the NFL Hall of Fame ceremonies on
Saturday night brutal to watch last
night
brutal yeah but I mean it's great its
back but gosh it just couldn't have been
more boring and you know these first
preseason games they're just not as
gonna be as good quality as they were
maybe eight ten years ago because of the
way the practice schedules are in
football now I mean it's just you know
okay so what would you do to make them
more entertaining
I honestly think there needs to be more
practice I think they're doing the
players that a disservice to themselves
in the last CBA I think the
veteran players in the NFL made the last
CBA too much about the veterans and then
here we got young guys that are going
man I got to play a game and I've got
like 10 practices in my belt and some of
them a lot of them weren't even the full
pads I haven't even tackled anybody so
that you know we talk about young
development in the NFL right now I think
that's a huge thing that's hindering it
is the new CBA rules I know a lot of my
coach friends complain about it and
they're not complaining about it because
they're like I'm just a psycho football
coach they're like legitimately like I
can't get guys ready in time for a week
one of the regular season because it's
half the practices it used to be by the
way our poll question is sponsored by
man versus food on Cooking Channel
McLovin if you update the results so far
from the first hour of the program okay
would you rather watch no preseason
games at all or have to watch every
preseason game that's about two games at
night eighty-three percent say no
preseason what would you do Chris Sims
well no I would go the other way but I'm
a psycho I mean gosh I didn't you know
I'm deep in the weeds in football so I
enjoy these preseason games as far as
just evaluating some of those young guys
we just talked about I mean it's in me
that's what the preseason is about I
want to see rookies I want to see some
second-year guys who didn't play a lot
as a rookie but now is gonna be expected
to be a contributor that's really what I
look for you know like hey Julio Jones
and and Aaron Rodgers and Odell Beckham
jr. I don't need to see them do crap in
pre-season I'm pretty sure you know
Julio we'll be able to catch a slant
when it comes week one and ready to go
help me with the philosophy of the
Dallas Cowboys right now with Jerry
Jones who loves any microphone put in
front of him therefore he's always gonna
be talking and saying something you set
the market for DeMarcus Lawrence yeah
you don't want to set the market for
your quarterback another your wide
receiver they're ever the Marty Cooper
and then your running back as well how
does this scenario play out in Dallas
yeah it's I mean a big question there a
Super Bowl contender there in the
Superbowl window I mean you know you
evaluate the roster and you go damn
there they're good at just about every
position on the field now because of
that I think is eql it has great
leverage because the offenses made about
running the ball keeping the you know
time of possession but can I pay him
first before I pay the guys who were up
before him III hear you I think
so at this point right now running back
to me and I think a lot of people in the
NFL it's a little bit of a different
entity altogether I mean it's the most
physical position and all the pro sports
I mean I don't think a heavyweight boxer
takes the blows that an NFL running back
does I mean it's every play it's just
one car crash after another we're
talking about a guy where yeah the team
is structured around him offensively
he's led the NFL in rushing to to the
last three years he's never heard he had
seventy seven receptions last year to
pay him to pay him more than Todd Gurley
'he's not gonna ruin their salary cap i
mean 15 million dollars a year's chump
change in the NFL right now i know it's
a lot of money but it's chump change for
a star player like Ezekiel Elliott so I
think eventually that gets done somehow
someway and then we'll be dak Prescott
where I think he'll probably one up a
Carson Wentz or something like that as
far as his contract I don't think he can
ask for Russell Wilson type money or or
Aaron Rodgers quite there but he'll just
one up a Carson Wentz and then Amari
Cooper who's made top five money already
who's gonna make 14 million dollars a
year I think he has to prove himself
just a little bit more and then maybe
next offseason he gets a contract that's
top five receiver type money I think
that's ultimately how I kind of envision
it playing out in my head we don't hear
very much about this quarterback yeah
and I'm curious Jerrod golf right well I
mean I think this is one of the like
things underlying things that people
aren't looking at in the NFL to me it's
just a peculiar that we're talking more
and we're farther down the line with dak
Prescott contract conversations right
now than we are with Jared Goff in the
Rams and I think that says a lot you
know I'm not saying it doesn't mean they
don't like Jared Goff but I think it's
telling they're telling you without
telling you right there that we'd like
to see just a little bit more we're not
sure if we want to throw 33 million
dollars at him yet ultimately I think
they will because I think they're gonna
be good and the public pressure and
everything's there but I think just
within that little what we're looking at
they're reading between the tea light
tea leaves I think it says a lot we got
clay Matthews coming up is Clay Matthews
and Hall of Famer man Clay's awesome
he's sixth among active players with
eighty three and a half sons yeah I'm
gonna say no an NFL legend
a Green Bay Packer hall-of-famer goes on
the Ring of Honor does all of that
well-liked by the media well I mean and
he's mean he's been a great football
player and to stick up for him in this
way too now he got screwed over by the
Green Bay Packers to a degree too
because he was a great football player
to where oh we have middle linebacker
issues we're gonna move you from the
position you're good at and take away
from your career sack status and put you
a middle linebacker and that's gonna
hurt that overall prospect too but I
think an NFL legend I think he maybe
just misses out of the Hall of Fame all
right some phone calls here for Chris
Simms John and Seattle leads us off this
final hour hi John oh thank you talking
about quarterbacks for Chris what what
can Aaron Rodgers our even Tom Brady do
that John Elway couldn't do and did it a
higher level he took a lot more abuse
back then before they protect a
quarterback like they do these days yeah
but I'd like to hear where you rank
Elway and not not for the two Super Bowl
wins but taking three marginal Bronco
teams to the Super Bowl I don't see
Aaron Rodgers on those teams or any of
these quarterbacks yeah oh I think Aaron
Rodgers could do what John Elway did and
again I know I'm in the minority John
Elway Dan you've heard me say this I
think he's the second greatest
quarterback of all time I would go
Rodgers Elway and then Tom Brady okay
and John Elway is another perfect
example of a little bit of a victim of
his own greatness I mean where we went
off I'll just lost three Super Bowls how
great is he and the real thing is what
our buddy there in Seattle was saying is
going no there's nobody else in football
that could have brought those teams to
the Super Bowl that's where it's unfair
to always get into that type of argument
you know it's like LeBron and a few
times at the cavaliers you're just like
I don't know many people in the history
of the NBA that could have brought this
team to the final but now we're gonna
criticize them for losing the final
that's where it's not fair Elway
phenomenal I don't know if he was like
I'll say this much it's precision as a
Brady in a Rogers like they can go
through periods of time where they're
surgical Elway could go through periods
of time where he might miss four or five
throws and you go Dan how does John
Elway missed that but then you know all
the sudden later in the quarter he's got
his mojo back and he
seven or eight throws rego whoa holy
crap like there's only like five people
in the history of the sport that could
hit that throw or made that run and
scramble and that's where Elway was good
but yeah I think that was probably the
area I look at where he's maybe not as
great as a Brady or a Rogers it's just
that surgical passing in the
intermediate game Dan in Wisconsin hi
Dan yeah my question is that all these
top rated quarterbacks seem to be
overrated because of the top five
defenses that they have unlike Tom Brady
he hit top ten defenses Joe Montana same
thing Brett Favre had Reggie White
Rodgers had Clay Matthews there for a
while sure my question is what about Dan
Marino Warren Moon even Lynn Dickey I'm
in Wisconsin yeah and you know these
guys are under waited because of the bad
defenses Dickie used to put up 40 points
but the other team would put up 45 yeah
I agree with everything you say they're
my top five quarterbacks of all time I
would have Dan Marino number five I
don't give a damn that he didn't win a
Super Bowl that's not fair again it's 52
other guys there's coaches involved it's
just not it's not fair to pin it on one
guy so this isn't and results as much as
it is playing ability just the playing
ability I'm just evaluating the player
like I've told you before where I said
Patrick mahomes did not have the best
year in college football a few years ago
he did was not the best player in
college football that year but when the
NFL evaluated quarterbacks they said oh
that's the best quarterback in college
football and that's why the Chiefs
traded up 18 picks same with John Elway
his senior year in Stanford same thing
they were what four and seven something
like that right but you know when it
came time to evaluate the quarterback
everyone know John Elway is the best
quarterback but his team wasn't there
good enough to you know put him in the
mainstream media and get all the hype
that way so that's yeah I do look at
that and Marino is grossly underrated
because of that aspect you know my
famous line is always this I mean if
we're gonna go buy Super Bowl wins and I
want everybody to start putting Phil
Simms in front of Dan Marino and Dan
might you know Big Daddy ain't better
today in it so sorry it's just that I'd
be lyin if that was the case you know
but who do you like more Marino or you
den well oh gosh I like my dad more but
I
I love Dan Marino I always have great
laughs of him he keeps it real he's you
know I'm a big Dan Marino fan all right
Nick and San Diego hey Nick your
question for Chris Sims what's up Danny
Boy hey what's going on Chris
they'll never fail buddy tails never
fails I question for Chris's mothership
today had Derek Carr as the number one
or the number two player to either step
up or step out and I just wanted to get
your intake of what he has to do and
with Antonio Brown as an addition in
your opinion but yeah no problem it's a
huge year for Derek Carr I mean I am in
the camp of if it's a below-average year
an average year that hey I know that
psycho Jon Gruden he will look to
replace you or at least make it a
competition next year if it doesn't go
smoothly I do believe in Derek Carr
still I think there's some physical
attributes there that I like let's not
forget the team of random stunk last
year is one of the worst offensive lines
he's battled little injuries the last
two years with the back and all that I
think their offense is gonna be tough to
deal with this year because I just think
Gruden and year two car and year two
he's got toys to play with Antonio Brown
hey we know that Tyrell Tyrell Williams
who came from the Chargers that was a
great addition so the receiving corps is
gonna be better the old line is gonna be
better and the other aspect that I think
is huge as their first-round pick Josh
Jacobs Josh Jacobs you heard it here
first will be their Alvin Kamara this
year you watch he's gonna be used in
that same way
Sean Payton Gruden that's the same type
of offense they know how to use the back
out of the backfield and I think you're
gonna see Josh Jacobs with Alvin Kamara
type stats maybe you know nine hundred
yards rushing and like seven hundred
yards receiving somewhere along those
lines I think they're often swill be a
handful for defenses this year and
Jacobs the running back out of Alabama
right Rick in California joins us hey
Rick your question for Chris Simms thank
you sir what do you have it my 49 years
yeah well okay I mean if you made me
better right now I'm still gonna give
the Rams the best record if I had to put
money down but I think the 49ers are one
of those teams that I've put a little
asterisk next to to say ooh
could be one of the risers of the league
this year well people thought that last
year then grop Logan hurt yes they did I
think people thought they could win 9
games last right and I can promise you I
was telling people to pump the brakes on
that last year I think this year is the
year that it sets up to be that way
Garoppolo is the big question mark we
really don't even know for a guy that's
making twenty seven point five million
it's amazing we don't really know
anything about the guy yet so there's
some you know unknowns there but the
team around him everything is going in
the right direction first of all the
defense was phenomenal there last year
it really improved
I think they're our top ten defense in
football now especially with Quan
Alexander D Ford Nick Bosa on the edge
so that I look at that aspect the
defensive line really good oh line
really good I mean it's the same unit
bringing back and they got a lot of good
players there with McGlinchey and Staley
and Weston Richburg who's one of the
better centers so they're gonna be good
there we know the Shanahan run game to
have him calm in there McKinnon they got
some receivers there now you know Dante
Pettis from last year's drought but
Jalen Hurd and then the kid from South
Carolina debo Samuel too where I go
watch out for the 49ers Jimmy Garoppolo
would be my if you have extra money and
you want to go see if you can hit the
jackpot at Vegas throw some money down a
Jimmy Garoppolo for MVP just one of
those like I would take a shot in the
dark with him because he he does have
talent Shanahan's offense is awesome I
think the team is gonna surprise people
and be in that wildcard conversation or
maybe even get into the wildcard to
where that usually lines itself up for
for MVP talk if you have suppose we know
less about Garoppolo yeah then we do dak
Prescott or Jared golf but we had no
problem paying Jimmy Garoppolo I because
if he came from another system other
than underneath Brady from the Patriots
that's a big part of it you're exactly
right Dan I mean that's that added to
the perception around him though he's
gonna be good bill like none of the
other guys who were there with Brady
have really developed no I think it is
all that and then desperation on the
49ers at the time if you remember they
were Owen ten and we were going oh gosh
what are they gonna ever win again
and I think they realized they they
definitely needed a quarterback they
couldn't wait for the free agency oh can
we get Kirk Cousins and what if we don't
then we're gonna be screwed over so I
think the desperation of the 49ers at
the time and then the New England factor
like you're bringing up played a big
part and yeah I mean that's where doc
Prescott probably starts his contract
contract negotiations it goes I would
think I mean I'm not taking less than
twenty seven and a half I know that
let's just work our way up when you make
your Superbowl pick coming up here in
the next I think two weeks or so I have
not there yet I got a hash to say I was
afraid you were gonna ask me that on the
car ride up here and I was kind of like
going to a hash okay I was trying to
throw out a name just in case he asked
me but I don't know there yet I'm not
ready for that you have a surprise pick
possibly you definitely I think okay I'm
teams that I think I'm not saying
playoffs we're gonna be in the
conversation right off the bat the Jets
and the Buffalo Bills I think are gonna
be a pain in the butt for a lot of teams
this year I'll say that so they might
make the play might make the playoffs
but I think you're gonna see dramatic
turnarounds from both organization with
you on the Jets okay okay now the other
team might say it was surprised the team
that I'd say watch out for to me and the
AFC more than anybody this year's the
Jacksonville Jaguars I think the
Jacksonville Jaguars the team that I'd
say to watch out for got injured last
year on the old line so that was a big
aspect of it yeah showed their
immaturity a little bit and when they
got injured on the o-line hey I hate to
go back here but then it made them have
to be a passing team and you know my
thoughts about the quarterback that was
there and hit on Nick Foles I'm sold on
him that would the right pieces around
him he can win football game I question
is yeah skilled position yep and his
Leonard fournette won't apply I get you
Leonard for nets the big question mark
he's a stud as far as talent is
concerned but they showed their
immaturity across the board last year
you know and I'm a huge Jalen Ramsey fan
but him spouting off before the year and
doing all that and yes you know you're
right with the fournette situation
fights it practice fights in the locker
room all of that but I just think the
defense is still one of the most
talented in football Doug Marrone great
o-line coach and they have a big
physical unit there and Sneaky wide
receivers and of course the nick foles
factor I look at and go yeah watch out
for Jacksonville you know who I love is
Paris Campbell Oh Dan I just think with
Andrew Luck uh-huh if he's healthy
ey Hilton Campbells could man is really
good I'm one of the most underrated
providers coming out in the draft I
thought I thought he was in the
conversation for the best receiver again
you know stats weren't you know always
like off the charts but he can do things
that other guys can't I mean
hey I just don't know a lot of receivers
in college football that year that could
take an end around and just go by the
Michigan defense down the sideline for
80 yards yeah didn't happen very much or
you know catch a short shallow cross and
then whoa oh my gosh he's outrun
everybody on the field once again I mean
those are special things those are you
know attributes that I look up where we
could set up to be a superstar thank you
for stopping by songs always you see I
hope that the the meat is ready to come
off the Trager grill so we can feed you
before you leave Chris okay thank you
very much I don't know if I can do meat
at 11:20 in the morning so we'll see
about that
I usually bring it home with me okay and
then eat it later okay okay okay cool
all right that's a Christians no longer
with bleacher report get it right GZ
only text me five times a week doesn't
know where I work for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]